let's talk about what to eat while
you're breastfeeding what you eat just
before during and after pregnancy will
determine your child's future health I
think this point is just not emphasized
enough it is so vitally important that
that child gets all the right nutrients
while they're developing so let's just
start at defining what a nutrient is
okay
nutrients are cofactors now that really
doesn't help you because what is the
cofactor cofactor our helper compounds
natural helper things that are essential
for building proteins okay now in your
mind you might be thinking proteins is
hair nail skin muscle but we want to
extend that definition way beyond that
all the enzymes in your body that create
all the digestion and the biochemical
reactions are proteins most of the
hormones are proteins you have proteins
that carry cholesterol as in high
density lipoproteins or low density
lipoproteins like HDL and LDL that's
protein hemoglobin the stuff in your
blood that helps you carry oxygen is
protein you have proteins that repair
the tissues that extend your life that
repair the DNA which are the blueprints
of the body you have proteins that
protect the cell against harmful things
you have your entire immune system as
protein that protects against microbes
and viruses you have proteins that are
like a mini copy machine for DNA the
blueprints you have proteins that are
proofreaders that help to look for
errors and go in there and actually fix
errors in your DNA it's incredible
you have proteins that help you detoxify
harmful chemicals so you need all these
nutrients involving in all these
different actions right here all the
pumps in the body that pump the fluid in
and out of the cells
so the cellular machinery that produces
energy called mitochondria has certain
nutrients that it needs
if the growing fetus or infant is
deficient in nutrients that child could
have all sorts of malfunctions with bone
okay their bone structure will not come
out correct
they will not be as tall the shape of
their jaw could be malformed where they
have an overbite or underbite the teeth
will be missing crooked you'll get
cavities
they'll need braces they'll be very
susceptible to getting sick because
their immune system will be suppressed
they could have mental or physical
disabilities a lower IQ just from having
a nutritional deficiency they could be
at risk for diabetes ad D asthma and
even cancer so you can see the
importance of these nutrients in the
early stages now how does a mother know
that she's deficient well I would look
at it the other way I would basically
start eating the foods that are very
high in those nutrients and not get hung
up on certain blood tests because a lot
of these nutrients are inside the cell
not in the blood they're intracellular
and they're hard to detect you could
identify nutritional deficiencies by
certain cravings you have for example if
you crave clay for example that could
mean that you have an iron deficiency if
you crave pickles it could mean that you
are deficient in potassium if you're
fatigued you could be deficient in iron
a vitamin b1 or even vitamin k2 if you
have no tolerance to stress you can be
deficient in vitamin b1 if you have no
endurance and you run out of gas all the
time that could mean that you'd need
more magnesium so now let's talk about
some of the really important nutrients
that are essential in developing this
this infant selenium very very important
because selenium is involved in making
sure mercury doesn't build up in the in
the body from the environment now even
if the child gets vaccinated which I
have my home
you point on that I don't want to open a
can of worms but they're gonna be
exposed to mercury selenium can help
counter mercury selenium is also
involved in the conversion of the
thyroid hormones from t4 to t3 slow liam
is a very powerful antioxidant then you
have iodine iodine is very important in
boosting the IQ and the growth of that
child if there is a deficiency in iodine
that child's going to be shorter and
they're gonna have a lower IQ the B
vitamins very very important in
developing a healthy heart developing
healthy brain involved in so many
different chemical reactions and also
the skin as well
folate you've probably heard about this
one if a child is deficient in folate
they can get something called neural
tube defects where the nervous system
does not form correctly and part of the
spinal column is exposed this is such an
easy thing to fix and folate comes from
the Greek foliage which is related to
leafy greens this is why you need to
start eating big salads very very
important not just for the folate but
for the minerals and for the vitamin C
then we have iron which is essential for
your red blood cells but if you're a
deficient iron that child will not grow
correctly and anemia is a very common
thing with kids now one side note I want
to make about this topic is that if
you're carrying your baby okay and
you're eating for two the fetus will get
the lion's share of nutrition so if
you're deficient in a nutrient you're
going to become really deficient because
that child is gonna get pretty much all
of that nutrients so you're gonna start
seeing symptoms yourself with maybe your
hair will start falling out of your
nails or or whatever but if you have any
of these symptoms realize it's usually a
nutritional deficiency and it means that
your diet is not correct okay so then we
have zinc probably one of the most
important nutrients behind vitamin D for
the immune system if you're deficient in
zinc the skin will not form correctly
there'll be low testosterone there's
over 2,000 chemical reactions that occur
just with this one trace mineral right
here
and over 1 billion people on this planet
are deficient in zinc and by the way if
you're eating a lot of refined carbs and
whole-wheat bread it's gonna deplete
your zinc sugar depletes zinc ok copper
works with zinc copper is part of the
vitamin C complex and copper is
essential in forming connective tissue
and I'm talking about joints too so
that's really important and facha
another part of your connective tissue
now we have calcium you want to get your
calcium from dairy to help with teeth
formation ok and bone formation
if you deficient in vitamin D and you're
breastfeeding the risk factor for
getting diabetes type 1 which is
autoimmune go way up the risk factor for
asthma goes way up the child's skeletal
structure may not form correctly they
may have bowed legs or even scoliosis
then we have vitamin A ok which is
essential for the vision then we have
manganese which is another trace mineral
that could potentially lead to flat feet
so as you can see there's a huge
influence on these nutrients and how
this baby is being developed you never
want to go low-fat if you're
breastfeeding or you're pregnant because
there's such a thing as essential fatty
acids omega-3 fatty acids this is the
big one right here DHA which is so
important to form the brain of that
child and the vision these 2 right here
very very important if you're taking a
prenatal by the way a lot of times I
don't even have this and they have a
bunch of synthetic vitamins and it's
they have soy in there and they have
very poor quality nutrients you always
want to get a whole food based prenatal
but you really need to fix the diet as
the most important thing now how can you
get some of these key trace minerals
like selenium iodine iron zinc copper
manganese shellfish okay very very
important and fish like in salmon you
want to get the wild caught it's much
better cod liver oil
essential these three things are really
important cod liver oil will provide
enough vitamin D and vitamin A and a DHA
fish will provide DHA minerals and
protein and shellfish will provide the
trace minerals you will also get the
trace minerals from fish and even organ
meats but a lot of people do not like
organ meats they can't seem to consume
liver and things like that you can get
this as a supplement but you can also go
to US wellness meats calm now I'm not
affiliated with that company I don't get
any kickbacks I just really like that
company because everything is not just
grass-fed and organic but it's
grass-finished and they have a hamburger
meat with organ meat in there and you
wouldn't necessarily taste those organ
meats it kind of camouflages the taste
but that would be very very good to
consume if you're breastfeeding or if
you're pregnant because you're gonna get
the trace minerals you're gonna get all
the vitamins and minerals organ meats
pretty much have every single nutrient
maybe not enough vitamin C but some of
the organ meats do and that's why you
need the salads right large deep leafy
greens to get the vitamin C and also the
minerals like potassium magnesium
nutritional yeast is vital for the B
vitamins it's one of the better sources
of natural B vitamins I would not
recommend the enriched nutritional yeast
get the one that's unfortified you can
get them in tablets as well eggs as
almost every single vitamin except
adamancy especially the egg yolks that
has the most nutrition this is very very
important and just make sure that when
you're buying food it's non-gmo and I'm
talking about organic if at all possible
because you don't want to add the extra
chemicals that can add problems like
birth defects and all sorts of toxicity
in their child alright I put a link down
below for more information on
a good formula that you can create and
additional information other foods that
you can eat but I at least wanted to
create the basics and emphasize the
importance of the diet and the nutrients
before you're pregnant during pregnancy
and after when you're breastfeeding
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications